now to the impeachment inquiry in
Washington where House Democrats are
trading angry charges with Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo Democrats say the
secretary could be involved in a quote
blatant cover-up and a clear abuse of
power after Pompeo accused them of
trying to intimidate State Department
officials into testifying sources tell
CBS News a former State Department
official and a former ambassador have
agreed to testify a short time ago
Pompeo confirmed he listened in on
president Trump's July 25th phone call
to Ukraine's president that triggered
the impeachment Pro Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill
Nancy what else did the secretary have
to say well it's a bit of a mystery Tony
all staffers here have been told is that
they're going to be shown documents
related to Ukraine but they don't know
whether these are documents that are
going to help the president's case or
hurt it it comes amidst a huge clash
between the State Department and
Congress over evidence and witnesses
what we objected to was the demands that
were put that are deeply violate
fundamental principles of separation of
powers secretary Pompeo broke his
silence about his role in a call between
Ukraine's president and president Trump
and he accused Democrats of pressuring
State Department officials to testify
right away we will of course do our
constitutional duty to cooperate with
this co-equal branch but we are going to
do so in a way that is consistent with
the fundamental values of the American
system overnight Democrats railed
against Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
after he said top officials needed more
time to prepare for congressional
interviews it's essentially saying don't
snitch and that's just about how we do
things in a blistering letter
Pompeyo accused Democratic leaders of
trying to bully State Department
officials into sitting for depositions
House Democrats fired back that Pompeo
may now be a fact witness in the
impeachment inquiry and that any attempt
to prevent witnesses from testifying
might indicate that he is trying to
cover-up illicit activity the State
Department's people could cooperate they
could come in immediately State
Department
after General Steve linic emailed
multiple congressional committees saying
he wants to discuss and provide staff
with copies of documents related to the
State Department and Ukraine the
briefing comes just two days after CBS
News and other outlets confirmed that
Pompeo was on the call where President
Trump asked the president of Ukraine to
investigate his campaign rival Joe Biden
and his son the president's allies
slammed the Congressional probe as a
coup and a trap they're putting them
through really an impeachment mockery we
may not know exactly what the State
Department's inspector general plans to
share with Congress today but we do know
that his job is to root out
mismanagement and wrongdoing at the
department so that could be a clue
Steve linic has been in the job gale
since 2013 he has a lot of autonomy and
he doesn't need the Secretary's
permission to come to Capitol Hill to
brief Congress should be a very
interesting appearance but Nancy let's
talk about this the president's personal
attorney is now hired an attorney as you
know Rudy Giuliani hired former
Watergate prosecutor John Sale to
represent him in this impeachment
inquiry so what have you heard about
their strategy on this well Giuliani
said last night on Fox that he's going
on the offensive he's thinking about
filing lawsuits against House Democrats
after he was subpoenaed for documents
stretching back two and a half years and
he particularly singled out House
Intelligence Chairman Adam Schiff he
said that what he's being subjected to
is quote worse than McCarthy Gale all
right Nancy thank you very much